I know you said children and babies and
donkeys all right
a book because you said okay okay okay
yeah okay but in your book it says go to
the woman and donkey I'm asking you know
they should motion anybody yes
daga is the messenger of what is wrong
we can't keep people kill let me tell
you is from
then why did you say you're all the same
to me
so winner so when I motion is evil but
when the music was his religion but when
he's a Muslim is it religion what about
central central Africa they're doing it
in the name of Jesus or sort of tune
about more than holes every when was on
that when was going to be crucified the
air of Luke chapter 19 verse 27 to say
that do you open it new chapter 19 verse
and he says if you open it something to
do Jesus ain't get you a sword out no no
yes those who've enough sword no those
who don't follow me bring them here and
slay them over them either bring them
here okay that's Jesus no food
traditions are loving our God born of
and why is he killing his enemies
Moses I'm sorry
yes judgment yes no nobody says bring
them here and lay them last look look
he's asking me to kill them and that's
why in central Africa you have the
Christians killing people in the name of
Jesus do I blink Christians no of course
not
there's bad in every religion see that's
what you haven't seen this verse before
right hey give me one thanks honey
subscribe